we want to find the derivative with
respect to x of all of this business
right over here and you might guess and
this is definitely a function of x x is
one of the boundaries of integration for
this definite integral and you might say
well the it looks like the fundamental
theorem of calculus might apply but i'm
used to seeing the x or the function x
as the upper bound not as the lower
bound how do i deal with this
and the key realization is to realize
what happens when you were if what
happens when you switch bounds for a
definite integral and i'll do a little
bit of an aside to review that so if i'm
taking the definite integral from a to b
of f of
of f of t
dt we know that this is capital f the
antiderivative of f evaluated at b
minus the antiderivative of f evaluated
at a this is essentially from th this is
corollary to the fundamental theorem or
the fundamental theorem part two or the
second fundamental theorem of calculus
this is how we this is how we evaluate
definite integrals
now let's think about what the negative
of this is so the negative of that of a
to b of f of t
dt is just going to be equal to the
negative of this which is equal to so
it's the negative of f of b
minus f of a
which is equal to capital f of a
minus capital f of b all i did is
distribute the negative sign and then
switch the two terms but this right over
here is equal to the definite integral
from
from instead of a to b but from b to a
b to a of f of t
f of t dt so notice when you put a
negative that's just like switching the
signs or switching the boundaries or if
you switch the boundaries they're the
negatives of each other so we can go
back to our original problem we can
rewrite this as being equal to the
derivative with respect to x
of
instead of
instead of this it'll be the negative of
the same definite integral with the
boundary switch the negative of x
with the boundaries the upper boundaries
x the lower boundary is 3
of the square root of the absolute value
of cosine t
dt which is equal to we can take the
negative out front negative times
negative times the derivative with
respect to x of all of this business i
should just copy and paste that
so i'll just copy and paste
and let me paste it so
times the derivative with respect to x
of all that and now the fundamental
theorem of calculus directly applies
this is going to be equal to we deserve
a drum roll now this is going to be
equal to the negative can't forget the
negative and the fundamental theorem of
calculus tells us that that's just going
to be this function as a function of x
so it's going to be negative
square root of the absolute value of
cosine of not t anymore
but x and we are done